When talking to you on a recent phone visit, you mentioned that you sell a supplement in your store
It is helpful to take after doing scans or
Tested involving radiation. Could you please name those supplements?
So we have two homeopaths for rate for
Radiation whether you're doing radiation as a therapy or you're doing a CT scanner or a PET scan
So those would be the scans that you're using radiation
One is called Radiogen by professional health products and the other one is our radiation homeopath
So if you just call Megan at the store, she can help you with that. Just call our store number
You'll see that on our store website. You can she can help you with that if you can't find that
That goes for you can't find something any any supplement that you're looking for
And you can't find it you understand you know, we don't have a whole lot of control over the search ability
Shopify
Megan and I
Frequently have words about how we feel about Shopify's searching capability or lack thereof
It's very frustrated the back end as well back end is even worse
So if you can't find something just always call the store if you're looking for it
But radiogen is the pH P product. I think our product is called radiation whole wheel path
Now if a person is doing a MRI
That's a different whole wheel path. So that's the gadolidium whole wheel path. So MRI with contrast that is so
gadolidium is a heavy metal that is used as a contrast agent for
MRIs with contrast and many people don't detoxify that very well
that effect when we do a
Heavy metal profile on people that have had MRIs
It's we can see whether they detoxify it or not
We've had we've done lots and lots of heavy metal panels on people and we get one get them back that they have had a lot of MRIs
With contrast and they don't show elevated gadolidium that means they're
Detox pathway for gadolidium. I don't know if it goes on the pun one pathway or some site of compete for 50 pathway
But that pathway is pretty clean and they're able to flush it under their system other people they have skyrocket high gadolidium levels
Beating that they just don't detoxify that well, and that's where that whole wheel path comes in play it can help pull that out
There's you want to do some other things to help don't that pathway as well, but that whole wheel path will help so the whole it
There's a whole wheel path for the radiation and that would be if you're doing radiation or you're doing a CT scan or pet scan or
Lot of x-rays or something and then there's a whole wheel path for gadolidium if you're doing a MRI with contrast